we are rolling through plenty of great
great guests chris sims mike florio and
there he is super bowl the great one for
champion sean payton one of the great
coaches in the national football league
here with us uh coach how are you good
i'm doing well i appreciate you guys
having me on uh
i'm excited about the games this weekend
i mean this game obviously it's always
difficult
not being in it especially this this
venue was 10 years ago for us for here
right here right so you kind of land and
you're like ah you know when you when
you have a good team but i think these
two teams are
gonna
uh are gonna make it a difficult game to
predict i think yeah both dub men are
explosive on offense um of course we
played san francisco but saw a lot of
kansas city film with some common
opponents so
uh
i think it'll be great for the great for
the league and the fans yeah uh do you
ever like just think about that you know
10 years ago that i mean the call maybe
the bravest call in the history
of the super bowl you're on side kick to
start the second half
there are a lot of
great memories but i would say what you
miss is you miss that
and i mean this wednesday's practice
you're on the bus back to the hotel
you're having dinner
meetings you're back to your room and
then you watch
you know you go to your room and every
one of us tonight when we go back to the
room at some point you're watching a
super bowl of pass right the next
morning breakfast practice like you
really want that week to go on because
there's there's this crazy party going
on out there that you're not a part of
you're sequestered really at practice
and in the hotel but you know what
you're doing is is is uh is real special
and there's nothing like that you know
yeah and so when the weekends even when
the game ends there's a little
postpartum like that that's it we don't
get to play anymore right right it's a
thursday edition of pro football talk
live nbc sports radio nbcsn hello once
again to our good friends in the uk and
in ireland on
sky sports enjoying the program look who
we have here look who we have here sean
payton one of the great coaches in the
national football league and you were
talking a minute ago about the surprise
onside kick from super bowl 44. and
there's been so much talk about what
they can do
to make the onside kick more of an
exciting play in the nfl although you
saw a few on site listen trust me go the
other way play us it'll be an exciting
play
seriously we're hoped for like four
we got everyone there i said darren
no we had we had our challenges with
that play
but overall we've seen the percentages
drop dramatically given the new
configuration the kickoff you can't have
the running start the onside kick such
an important part of the game not just
from a surprise standpoint but when a
team is trailing by multiple scorers
late in the game you want to give that
team a chance to get back into it do you
have any thoughts as a member of the
competition committee on this fourth and
fifth i'm not a big fan of the fourth
and fifteen me neither and and one
quarterback's going to get hit and his
shoulder is going to get separated on
4th and 15 and you're going to say
quickly you know i understand the safety
relative to the onside kick i think we
can improve prove
i think we can improve how we do it
right now inside of three minutes you
know let's allow maybe a little bit more
flexibility but there's not i think the
most exciting finish
to an nfl game or any game for that
matter is score
onside kick recover score right like
that and that's happened a handful of
times and and to be on the winning end
of that which i have been and also on
the losing end of it uh
so
i i think the mindset of looking at ways
to to
we we have to
keep that opportunity alive in other
words we can't we can't have a team
taking a knee with with with more time
left than than we do right now right and
i think that we will and and i think it
was discussed last year it was brought
up uh but i think
we're going to pay a little bit more
attention to just the actual onside kick
itself um
but what has changed is the alignment on
kickoffs in general and so i don't know
10 years ago
if we opened the second half with the
current configuration of where eight
players are yeah right we were counting
on hank baskett to leave and he actually
played it pretty played it pretty well
yeah he stayed at home right and so
um
you you statistically are just going to
have less surprise attempts but how do
we uh how do we improve the obvious
onside kick one was something we're
looking at when did you know you were
going to call it like what day of the
week did you finally go you know what
i'm pretty sure i'm going to come out in
the second half dude it started with we
were looking for an opportunity to steal
possession peyton was playing so well
their offense was playing so well you
know the concern we had was we're back
here in miami they just did won a super
bowl here three years prior against
bears they're at the same hotel room
um
and part of it was also we're playing to
win this game so there's two elements
that go into that literally trying to
take a possession away but also your
team understanding hey we're going to be
aggressive right so
the night before and i would rarely talk
in a special teams meeting and just
grabbed everyone for five minutes and i
said hey we've had a great week all
right and it's gonna come down to the
details i mean
garrett hartley hit three he was three
for three at field goals over 40 yards
that was that was significant meanwhile
they miss a 41 yarder and leave us field
position
but
the message was we're going to be
aggressive and when when we call this
and i'm telling you we're calling it i
can't tell you when we're going to call
it you guys got to make make me right
and then defense you're ready for a
quick change
so
that was that and then it wasn't until
halftime and then there were a few
mistakes that were almost made you know
the direction we were traveling
initially were going to be left to right
which would have put that kick
on the colts sideline and so
we had
we had the ball on offense in the first
half that means we chose which end we
wanted to defend and i chose the wrong
end heading into the locker room
made the decision came back out and then
quickly said wait a minute i want to go
the other way right and so when you have
a scrum like we had for five minutes the
longest crumb i've ever seen and it
helps if it's on your
it
sideline
hurt we got it we got it yeah enough
people are yelling saints balls right so
um
no it uh and look credit the players and
and what was what was most important
though wasn't just recovering it was the
sixth five sixth place sequence
following that scored a touchdown yeah
and look indy came back and scored that
very next series so it just got momentum
going but it also left payton
you know that half ended with us kicking
a field goal
and then started with us
and it just seemed like there was an
hour and a half went by before peyton
was back underneath the center right and
that's a long time yes it is when the
chiefs and the 49ers play in the super
bowl on sunday will you be able to watch
it as a fan can you ever turn off that
that constant looking and probing
something for next year that i can glean
from this game from either team it's
hard
um
yeah
i try to make sure
you watch it in an environment where you
can kind of hear hear the broadcast
right and
and watch the game as opposed to we've
all been in that environment where you
know you're kind of there's a lot going
on and all of a sudden it's half time
yeah you know i and i
hopefully uh and i think we'll be able
to this year um
yeah but
look both of these teams do a lot of
good things offensively and
uh they're extremely fast both of them
yeah and and you feel it when you watch
them and we we played san francisco and
you got a chance firsthand to see these
guys the running backs and and debose
you know this young receiver watching
him run and move family yeah man he's
going to get three or four handoffs and
and you're going to have to defend him
right in the running game and then
obviously what kansas city does with
their speed so there are two teams that
you can feel their speed but to answer
your question
it's it's it's a little different i mean
i i know this i can eat like the regular
fan can during the game i don't know if
i can watch it the same way but
certainly gravitate to all the things
worry about your meat right yeah
everybody absolutely right yeah that's
right
we're going to whole foods after a game
amazing you just want to relax oh one of
the best responses
of the year that was a good story though
from alvin kamara he was here earlier
this week on that same topic not meat
though but fish what's with throwing up
the beginning room after you beat so we
we have we always have some type of like
unique celebration after a win you know
and depending on the team you play you
know and so we we we always see
the seattle scene and it's fox they cut
the you know the the fish market yeah
and so right uh so it was players of the
game practice squad players and we had
man i'm telling you we had a cooler full
of these fish and i didn't realize how
big they were it was all planned but not
literally practice and we got down there
and jromic and our staff do a great job
and i'm trying to haul these fish and
and it was difficult because the the
team meeting room was on a slope the
fish weighed like 40 pounds and then
years ago crazy fish is flying around in
this we had like 14 fish and then i've
got somebody who's allergic and and he's
he's telling me not to throw it and i'm
like no i'm throwing it he's like no no
you can't
and
it just you know it starts wednesday off
with the that's a good vibe yes we've
done a lot of different things and alvin
said the the meeting room stunk like
dead fish for the rest of the week i'm
telling you you're still going there
right now and you're like it's still
smelly it's just a little no that
doesn't go away right right it's like
the car in seinfeld yeah yeah yeah no
doubt about it with um you know there
was always talk about how interested you
you were patrick mahomes coming out in
the draft yeah you know just take us
back to one absolutely what jumped out
to you about him then and just what he's
become now so we spent a day there we
you know had an individual day we were
we were um picking at 11.
and uh
you what you saw on film were some of
these off schedule throws you saw arm
strength really good arm talent right um
they threw it a lot there it was a lot
on him in the offense he was playing so
you know it's a four wide set he's
getting blitzed you know a lot of times
they're shortened protection and he just
was the spaghetti sauce
uh for for a decent team not a great
team right and so then it was like the
second element you've done all your tape
studying which was uh pretty exhausting
we go there for a day
and it was an interesting day we started
there we ended up at tennessee saw
kamara ended up uh in ohio state uh
working out lattimore and those guys
holy cow and um
but
he was he was exceptional in in the
meeting that we had we did you know we
do a series of tests in in a room
uh
we give them the install actually send
it to them in an email the night before
put it up on the board go through it
take us through it we spent the better
part of a whole day had lunch with him
later on and he was very impressive and
certainly a guy that was a targeted
player for us and so here here the draft
comes and
the one thing that was unique is
marshawn lattimore was sliding right so
now
in a draft room you've got a player
maybe with a tick higher grade the
corner right and yet you've got a
potential franchise quarterback so
there's always that dilemma right and uh
you know
that continued to slide and then when
you're in our seat you want if two of
them
fall to 10 you know you got one of these
guys right
and and both fell to 10. yeah and then
andy went to 10. yeah and
the the question that we've never really
answered is what would we have done at
11 with both available and i
uh i don't know if we if we would have
uh
changed because lattimore's grade was so
good yeah he's great you know you know
you're looking at a corner
uh and
there's always that in it the thinking
is is challenging there's always that
it's lattimore helps your team
immediately with breeze the other player
helps your team long term and so yeah we
deal with that a lot right yeah well
just one quick follow-up with the
mahomes thing like was one of those
things when you first saw him throw
during that workout were you like
fantastic right you were like oh my gosh
i've cause i saw that person last year
and i just the first throw i was like
he's fantastic yeah
we saw a lot of uh a lot of traits that
you saw with brett right when you watch
far play and so his film was one thing
we couldn't wait to get down there and
uh
we felt like we were there eight hours
yeah and he was tremendous in the film i
mean
he was so such a likable guy
and as you as we all get older these
players seem younger and younger and
younger and he was one of those guys
that you know i was you just you watched
them and you just saw a high ceiling
yeah you know definitely there's an old
saying in football that if you have two
quarterbacks you have none you've got
three
and you've got three and they're
absolutely and how is this going to play
out for the saints next year well it's a
great question um i it'll start
obviously in the next few weeks here
with drew uh he and i spoke a little bit
after the season before the pro bowl
i think he's gonna spend time with his
family and really give some thought to
uh you know playing again next year and
and
this will this will end the right way in
other words you know i'm excited with
the opportunity of him possibly coming
back i'd love to have him back we
thought he played at a high level yep um
and yet a little bit of time here at the
end of the season i think is healthy for
him
and then i think that that's step one
before you get into
taysom and teddy and and
we were fortunate we felt like we had a
great room with with those three players
um we relied on teddy you know and and
he went 5-0 with us and so when drew get
got back you know we kind of there were
a few things we changed while drew was
gone you know teddy changed up when we
met to go through the saturday night
before the
the game the final plays we dot plays
you know we decided to do that before
the snack not after and that was
different
and then so by the time drew got back he
was gone for three or four weeks in l.a
we're like no we we're doing this now
yeah
right
the message is for for all of us really
is whenever we leave the train keeps
going right and uh no and and then of
course taysom uh is is doing more and
more things and uh he's incredible yeah
the best player on the field for either
team in your playoff game i'm firmly
convinced yeah yeah i mean he's
impressive i mean and you you've got to
be impressed with just every year it
seems like the throwing and the decision
making is the question gets better right
no question he
one thing is hard to uh
the people that aren't in our division
you know the the atlanta tampa bay i
think carolina see enough of each other
but his strength
relative to is his lower body and his
ability to
to to block and leverage people he he
just loves playing football and and so
when you watch him it's it's kind of
contagious you know you see it with our
with our sideline hey coach we know you
got a lot to do today before we let you
go tell us what you have going on with
zebra technologies
look we we've been partnered with zebra
now the saints uh for over three years
the league is and it's just player
tracking you know our ability to
put chips in the shoulder pads right we
we partnered strictly for injury
uh reduction training camp you know when
we we talk about reducing a practice how
long we're on the field but it's it's
it's doing so much for us now besides
that you know we're able to help it in
the evaluation process the senior bowl
this year these players are tracked so
when you go back to watch the film of
patrick mahomes you don't have to wait
you can get all the plays right away
you're not looking at socks to see if
this is the right corner in the game
it's in the balls now you know we're
able to track rotation of ball spin rate
um i think you're gonna it's not long
before we see this thing
you know helping us with the ball
crossing the plane how about the punt
that goes out of bounds and the one
official runs until the other one waves
his hand right like that's like the most
unexact science ever yeah there ever
could be right and but it's for for
everyday use our our fans see it at
target you know and it's a simple
barcode system that helps you just
locate track and and be more accurate
all right toughest thing all day right
here right now who's going to win the
super bowl man yup
listen i'm looking at both these bobble
heads first off you got you got a color
rush game going on because they're both
in like dark jerseys yeah right don't
want to be comfortable we did like the
red and the green right nobody thought
of
honestly seriously yeah can we always
have a white jersey yeah uh yes so i'm
i'm avoiding your question okay good job
i i'm going to say this though
this this number 10 from eastern
illinois yeah yeah
spent a lot of time talking about texas
tech here and i'm just saying yeah i
hear you giving him some respect he
deserves it and you saw it you saw it at
home what he can do with the game on the
line absolutely we haven't seen it it's
not his fault they can't stop him from
running the football right that's green
bay's problem yeah right but he he had a
great year and uh i honestly i'm excited
to watch this game yeah good good job
dodging the question you're a pro i have
to i mean
it's all good don't worry great seeing
you as always thanks for including us on
your tour on behalf of zebra technology
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports